the Board of Nursing could be impacted I
spoke to the executive director who says
she'd like to see it become easier for
out-of-state nurses to work here one of
the things that we are constantly
talking about internally and with our
board is that we don't want to create
unnecessary barriers for uh licensure
the Board of Nursing can issue a
temporary license to someone in four or
five days if they meet certain
requirements but it's that weight that
slows hospitals who need to quickly fill
open positions especially during
emergency situations meeting nurses
quickly is is so important and so if
there's something that we can do to help
decrease those barriers that's what
we're going to do Lombardo is ordering
all occupational and Professional
Licensing boards to suspend the creation
of new regulations then they need to
review existing regulations and
determine how they could align with what
other states are doing Nevada is the
second worst regulated State when it
comes to occupational licensing
particularly when we look at lower and
lower middle income occupations the
Nevada policy Research Institute
supports these changes Marco Lopez says
Barbers and interior designers in
particular are heavily regulated in the
state and it places an undue burden on
those looking to climb the economic
ladder we are one of four states that
license interior designers
um and you know I don't know about you
but I don't think you need to have a
license spend almost a thousand dollars
in fees do a bunch of training just to
tell someone that their couch doesn't
match their drapes the governor says
this is about making the state economy
Fair open competitive and inclusive
reporting at UMC near Charleston and
Alta Joshua eight news now and in
regards to nursing there is currently a
bill being proposed that would allow
Nevada to be part of a multi-state
compact meaning nurses with an
out-of-state license could immediately
work here in town